هناك ثغرات كبيرة في
قصة Moskva ، السفينة الرئيسية
لأسطول البحر الأسود الروسي ، وهي سفينة حربية تقع الآن
في قاع البحر
، توصف بأنها أكبر
خسارة في زمن الحرب لسفينة بحرية منذ 40 عامًا ، لكن
هناك القليل جدًا من المعلومات التي تم فحصها
حول ما  حدث
أنه لم يكن هناك صحفيون ولا شهود
عندما بدأت السفينة في الغرق ، لذا فإن
ما تبقى لدينا هو قصة مبارزة
مع أوكرانيا تدعي أنها ضربتها
بمضادات للسفن والصواريخ
وتحاول روسيا القول بخلاف ذلك مدعيا
اندلاع حريق على متنها  السفينة الحربية
التي تسببت في انفجار الذخائر ،
وهذا ما ألحق الضرر بالسفينة
وأجبر الطاقم على إخلاء
قصة أكثر تعقيدًا
، ولا توجد طريقة لوصول منافذ الأخبار
حقًا إلى قاعها ،
ولكن ضع في اعتبارك
أن الطاقم العادي على متن سفينة Moskva سيكون
كذلك  حوالي 500 بحار
500.
لا نعرف ما إذا
كان الطاقم بأكمله على متن السفينة عندما بدأت السفينة في الغرق ،
لكننا نعلم أنه في مجتمع حر
، أفراد الأسرة والجيران و
سيطلب المشرعون إجابات
من الحكومة ،
ثم مرة أخرى نعلم أيضًا أن روسيا ليست
مجتمعًا حرًا ،
حتى إذا طرحنا أسئلة حول هذا الأمر قد
يرفع الأعلام الحمراء في موسكو ،
الآن أصدرت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
بعض مقاطع الفيديو يوم السبت هنا
تظهر العشرات من البحارة المزعوم
أولئك الذين هربوا من
Moskva عدد البحارة في هذا التشكيل
غير واضح
ولكن ليس 500
وبحار يبدو أنهم جدد بشكل ملحوظ بالنسبة
لمجموعة عانت للتو من
إنقاذ مروّع في شكوك البحر ،
يجب أن يتم تطبيقها بحرية كبيرة على هذا
طاقم واحد على الأقل الآن.
تم الإبلاغ عن مقتل أحد الأعضاء
وتم حزنه علنًا على
أحد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الروسية ، حيث
نشرت أرملة أن زوجها اقتبسها حارب حتى
أنفاسه الأخيرة طوال حياة السفينة ،
لذلك نعلم أنه من خلال منشور ضال على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
كم عدد الأشخاص الذين كانوا مثله كيف  العديد من
الأشخاص الآخرين
في الحرب ،
حتى أن العديد من القتلى لم يتم إحصاؤهم
في أوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي ،
لم يتم إخبارهم حتى عن القصص التي لم يتم إخبارها ،
هل سنعرف القصة كاملة.  من
Moskva
أو سيتم تشويهها عن طريق
الدعاية والحقيقة لم تكشف